the following content is provided under
a creative commons license your support
will help mit opencourseware continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of mit courses
visit mit opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
all right so like i told you guys friday
marked the end of the hardest part of
the course and
monday marked the end of the hardest
pset so because the rest of your classes
are going full throttle this one's going
to wind down a little bit
so today i'd say sit back relax and
enjoy a nuclear catastrophe
because we are going to explain what
happened at chernobyl now that you've
got the physics
and
intuitive background to understand the
actual sequence of events
to kick it off i want to show you guys
some actual footage
of the chernobyl reactor as it was
burning so this is the part that most
folks know about
this is footage taken from a helicopter
from folks that were either surveying or
dropping materials onto the reactor
was probably a bad idea
hold where the smoke is we'll get into
what the smoke was
so that
red stuff right there that's actually
glowing graphite amongst other materials
from the graphite fire that resulted
from the rbmk reactor burning after the
chernobyl accident caused by both
flaws in the physical design of the rbmk
reactor and absolute operator stupidity
and neglect of any sort of safety
systems or safety culture we're lucky to
live here in the u.s where our worst
accident at three mile island was not
actually really that much of an accident
there was a partial meltdown there was
not that much of a release of
radionuclides into the atmosphere
because we do things like build
containments on our reactors
if you think of what a typical reactor
looks like like if you consider the mit
reactor is a scaled down version of a
normal reactor all right
let's say a commercial power reactor
you've got the core here you've got a
bunch of shielding around it
and you've got a dome
that's rather thick
that comprises the containment
that would be the core
this would be some shielding
so this is what you find in u.s and most
other reactors for the rbmk reactors
there was no containment
because it was thought
that nothing could happen and boy were
they wrong
so i want to walk you guys through a
chronology of what actually happened at
the chernobyl reactor which you guys can
read on the nea or nuclear energy agency
website the same place that you find
janus and we're going to refer to a lot
of the janus cross sections to explain
why these sorts of events happened
so the whole point of what happened at
chernobyl was it was desired to see if
you could use the spinning down turbine
after you shut down the reactor to power
the emergency systems at the reactor
this would be following something what's
called a
loss of off-site power
if the off-site power or the grid was
disconnected from the reactor the
reactor automatically shuts down but the
turbine like i showed you a couple weeks
ago is this enormous spinning hulk of
metal and machinery that coasts down
over a long period of let's say hours
and as it's spinning the generator coils
are still spinning and still producing
electricity or they could be so it was
desired to find out can we use the
spinning down turbine to power the
emergency equipment if we lose offsite
power so they had to simulate this event
so what they actually decided to do is
coast down the reactor to a moderate
power level or very low power and see
what comes out of the turbine itself or
out of the generator rather
now there were a lot of flaws in the
rbmk design and i'd like to bring it up
here so we can talk about what it looks
like and what was wrong with it
so the rbmk is unlike any of the
united states light water reactors that
you may have seen before many of the
components are the same there's still a
light water reactor coolant loop where
water flows around fuel rods
goes into a steam separator better known
as a big heat exchanger and the steam
drives a turbine
which produces energy
and then this coolant pump keeps it
going and then the water circulates
what makes it different though is that
each of these fuel rods was inside its
own pressure tube so the coolant was
pressurized and out here
this stuff right here was the moderator
composed of graphite
unlike light water reactors in the us
the coolant was not the only moderator
in the reactor
graphite also existed which meant that
if the water went away which would
normally shut down a light water reactor
from lack of moderation graphite was
still there to slow the neutrons down
into the high fission cross section area
and i'd like to pull up janus
and show you what i mean with the
uranium cross section
so let's go again to uranium-235
and pull up its fission cross section
z fission
can make it a little thicker too
so
again the goal of the moderator is to
take neutrons from high energies like 1
to 10 mev where the fission cross
section is relatively low and slow them
down into this region where fission is
let's say a thousand times more likely
and in a light water reactor in the u.s
if the coolant goes away so does the
moderation and there's nothing left to
slow those neutrons down to make fission
more likely in the rbmk
that's not the case the graphite's still
there
the graphite is cooled by a helium
nitrogen mixture because the neutron
interactions in the graphite that's
slowing down
we've always talked about what happens
from the point of view of the neutron
but what about the point of view of the
other material
any energy lost by the neutrons is
gained by the moderating material so the
graphite gets really hot and you have to
flow some non-oxygen containing gas
mixture like helium and nitrogen which
is pretty inert to keep that graphite
cool
and then in between the graphite
moderator where control rods about 200
of them or so 30 of which were required
to be down in the reactor at any given
time in order to control power and that
was a design rule that was broken during
the actual experiment
and then on top of here on top of this
biological shield you could walk on top
of it so those the tops of those
pressure tubes despite being about 350
kilo chunks of concrete
you could walk on top of them it's
pretty cool
kind of scary too
so what happened in chronological order
was around midnight the decision was
made to undergo this test and start
spinning down the turbine
but the grid operator came back and said
no you can't just cut the reactor power
to nothing you have to maintain at a
rather high power for a while about 500
megawatts electric or half the rated
power of the reactor and what that had
the effect of doing is continuing to
create fission products including xenon
135
we haven't mentioned this one yet
you'll talk about it quite a lot
in
2205 in neutron physics this black shirt
really shows chalk well okay
what xenon 135 does is it just sits
there it's a noble gas it has a
half-life of a few days so it decays on
the slow side for
you know fission fission products go but
it also absorbs lots and lots and lots
of neutrons
let's see if i can find which one is the
xenon one there we go
so here i've plotted the total cross
section for xenon 135 and the absorption
cross section
and notice how for low energies pretty
much the entire cross-section of xenon
is made up of absorption did you guys in
your homework see anything that reached
about 10 million barns
no
xenon-135 is one of the best neutron
absorbers there is and reactors produce
it constantly so as they're operating
you build up xenon 135 that you have to
account for in your sigma absorption
cross section
because like you guys saw in the
homework
if you want to write what's the sigma
absorption cross section of the reactor
it's the sum
of every single isotope in the reactor
of its number density
times
its absorption cross section
and so that would include everything for
water
and let's say the uranium and the xenon
that you're building up
when the reactor starts up the number
density of xenon is zero because you
don't have any anything to have produced
it
when you start operating you'll reach
the xenon equilibrium level where it
will build to a certain level that will
counteract
the reactivity of the reactor
and in your k effective expression
where its sources
over
absorption plus leakage
this has the effect of rise raising
sigma absorption and lowering k
effective
the trick is it doesn't last for very
long it both decays with a half-life of
about five days and when you try and
raise the reactor power you will also
start to burn it out so if you're
operating at a fairly low power level
you'll both be decaying and burning
xenon without really knowing what's
going on and that's exactly what
happened here
so an hour or so later
let me pull up the chronology again
a little more than an hour later so the
reactor power stabilized at something
like 30 megawatts and they were like
what is going on why is the reactor
power so low we need to increase the
reactor power so what do they do couple
things
one was remove all but six or seven of
the control rods
going way outside the spec of the design
because 30 were needed to actually
maintain the reactor at a stable power
all the while the xenon that had been
building up
is still there keeping the reactor from
going critical it's what was the main
reason that the reactor didn't even have
very much power
but it was also burning out at the same
time
so all the while
let's say if we were to show a graph of
two things time
xenon inventory and
as a solid line
and let's say control rod worth
as a dotted line
the xenon inventory at full power would
have been at some level and then it
would start to decay and burn out
while at the same time the control rod
worth as you
remove control rods from the reactor
every time you remove one you lose some
control rod worth would continue to
diminish
leading to the point where bad stuff was
going to happen
let me make sure i didn't lose my place
so at any rate as they started pulling
the control rods out a couple of
interesting quirks happened in terms of
feedback so let's look back at this
design
like any reactor
this reactor had what's called a
negative fuel temperature coefficient
what that means is that
when you heat up the fuel
two things happen one the cross section
for anything absorption or fission would
go up
but the number density would also go
down as the atoms physically spaced out
in the fuel their number density would
go down lowering the macroscopic cross
section for fission and that's arguably
a good thing
the problem is at below about twenty
percent power the reactor had what's
called a positive void coefficient
which meant that if you boil the coolant
you increase the reactor power
because the other thing that i think i
mentioned this once
and you calculated in the homework
the absorption cross section of hydrogen
is
not zero it's small but fairly
significant let's actually take a look
at it because we can always see this in
janus
we go back down to hydrogen
hydrogen one
and we look at the absorption cross
section
and of course it started us with a
linear scale let's go logarithmic ah
okay
so at low energies that you know 10 to
the minus 8 to 10 to the minus seven
it's around a barn
not super high but absolutely not
negligible
which meant that part of the normal
functionality the rbmk depending up
depended on the absorption of the water
to help absorb some of those neutrons
with those neutrons gone i'm sorry with
those with that water gone
there was less absorption but there was
still a ton of moderation
in this graphite moderator so they still
could get slow but then there'd be more
of them and that would cause the power
to increase and then that caused more of
the water the coolant to boil which
would cause
less absorption which would cause the
power to increase yeah charlie
they did not remove the water from the
reactor however as the power started to
rise some of the water started to boil
and so you can still have let's say
steam flowing through
and still remove some of the heat
however you don't have that denser water
to act as an absorber
and that's what really undid this
reactor in addition they decided to
disable the eccs or the emergency core
cooling system which you're just not
supposed to do so they shut down a bunch
of these systems to see if you could
power the other ones from the spinning
down turbine
and
then as they noticed that the reactor
was getting less and less stable they
had almost all the rods out
some of these pressure tubes started to
bump and jump
these 350 kilogram
pressure tube caps were just rattling i
mean imagine something that weighs you
know 900 pounds or so rattling around
and there's a few hundred of them so
there was someone in the control room
that said the caps are rattling what the
heck
didn't quite make it down the spiral
staircase because about 10 seconds later
everything went wrong
and so i want to pull up this actual
timeline so you can see
it splits from minutes to seconds
because the speed at which this stuff
started to go wrong
was pretty striking
so for example the control rods raised
at 1 19 in the morning
two minutes later
when the power starts to become unstable
the caps on the fuel channels which
again are like 350 kilogram blocks start
jumping in their sockets
and a lot of that was we go back to the
rbmk reactor
as the coolant started to boil here well
that boiling force actually creates huge
pressure instabilities which would cause
the pressure tubes to jump up and down
eventually rupturing almost every single
one of them with enough force to shoot
these
350 kilo caps
and what did that what did they say
i like the
language that they used jumping in their
sockets
so
50 seconds later
pressure fails in the steam drums which
means there's been some sort of
containment leak so all the while
the coolant was boiling the absorption
was going down the power was going up
repeat repeat repeat and the power
jumped to about a hundred times the
rated power in something like four
seconds
so it was normally a thousand megawatt
electric reactor which is about 3200
megawatts thermal it was producing
nearly
yeah half a terawatt of thermal power
for a very short amount of time until it
exploded
now the it's interesting a lot of folks
called chernobyl a nuclear explosion
that's actually a misnomer a nuclear
explosion would be a nuclear weapon
something set off by an enormous chain
reaction principally heated by fission
or fusion that's not actually what
happened at chernobyl nor at fukushima
nor was that the worry at three mile
island not to say it wasn't a horrible
thing but it wasn't an actual nuclear
explosion
at first what happened
was a pressure explosion
so
there was an enormous release of steam
as
the power built up to 100 times normal
operating power the steam force was so
large that it actually blew the reactor
lid
up off of the thing
i think i have a picture of that
somewhere here too
it should be further down yeah to give
you a little sense of scale the reactor
cover which weighed about a thousand
tons launched into the air
and landed above the reactor
sending most of the reactor components
up to a kilometer up in the air
four seconds later
that was followed by a hydrogen
explosion
let me get back down to that chronology
so yeah
at 123 and 40 seconds in the morning oh
yeah so i should mention why this
happened emergency insertion of all the
control rods
the last part that this diagram doesn't
mention is these control rods and i'll
draw this up here we're tipped with
about six inches of graphite
so if these were two graphite channels
let's say these are carbon
and this is your control rod
the goal was to get this control rod
all the way into the reactor
one part they didn't mention
was they were tipped with about six
inches of graphite which only functions
as additional moderator graphite is one
of the lowest absorbing materials in the
periodic table second i think only to
oxygen
and if we pull up graphite's cross
sections
i've plotted here the total cross
section
the elastic scattering cross section and
down here in the
0.001 barn level is the absorption cross
section about a thousand times lower
than water so you're shoving more
material in the reactor that slows down
neutrons even more bringing them into
the high fission region without
absorbing anything and they jammed about
halfway down about two and a half feet
down leaving the extra graphite right in
the center of the core where it could do
the most damage and it didn't take that
much time yeah um so my understanding is
that also one of the designs was that
the control rods didn't like immediately
drop down but they were slowly lowered
yep so they took they took seven to ten
seconds okay if they had a system where
they did drop them would that have
possibly actually shut the system down
properly i'm not sure i don't know
whether lowering control rods into
something that was
undergoing steam explosions would have
actually helped
me to me by this point it was all over
um
whether or not you know so the extra the
extra abs what is it the extra moderator
that was dumped in was the last kick in
the pants this thing needed to go
absolutely insane
and if we go back to the timeline on the
second level control rods inserted at
123 and 40 seconds explosion four
seconds later ah to 120 times full power
getting towards a terror water so one
second later the thousand ton lid
launches off from the first explosion
very shortly after that second explosion
and that happened because of this
reaction
well
any just about anything
corroding with water
will make pretty much anything oxide
plus hydrogen
the same chemical explosion that was the
undoing of fukushima and was the worry
at three mile island that there was a
hydrogen bubble building because of
corrosion reactions with whatever
happened to be in the core this happens
with zirconium pretty vigorously but it
happens with other materials too
if you oxidize something with water you
leave behind the hydrogen and the
hydrogen in a very wide range of
concentrations in the air is explosive
we're actually not allowed to use
hydrogen at about four percent
in any of the labs here because that
reaches the flammability or explosive
limit so we were doing some for my phd
we were doing these experiments
corroding
materials in liquid lead and we wanted
to dump in pure hydrogen to see what
happens when there's no oxygen we were
told absolutely not we had to drill a
hole in the side of the wall so that the
hydrogen would vent outside
and do some calculations to show if the
entire bottle of hydrogen emptied into
the lab at once which it could do if the
cap of the bottle breaks off it would
not reach four percent concentration
so hydrogen explosions are pretty
powerful things have you guys ever seen
people making water from scratch
mix hydrogen and oxygen in a bottle and
light a match
we've got a video of it circulating
somewhere around here because for rtc
for the reactor technology course i do
this in front of a bunch of ceos watch
them jump out of their chairs to teach
basic chemical reactions but it's pretty
loud enough
about enough hydrogen and oxygen
to just fill this cup or fill a half
liter water bottle makes a bang that
gets your ears ringing not quite
bleeding but
close enough
so that's what happened here except on a
much more massive scale so there was a
steam explosion followed seconds later
by a hydrogen explosion from hydrogen
liberated from the corrosion reaction of
everything with the water that was
already there
and that's when
this happened
is
so that's smoke right there
from a graphite fire
not normal smoke
[Music]
spoke too soon
[Music]
foreign
this actually provides a perfect conduit
to transition from the second to the
third parts of this course a lot of you
have been waiting to find out what are
the units of dose and what are the
biological and chemical effects of
radiation well this is where you get
them from neutron physics you can
understand why chernobyl went wrong with
honestly you've just been doing this for
three or four weeks but with your
knowledge of cross-sections reactor
feedback and criticality you can start
to understand why chernobyl was flawed
in this design and what we're going to
teach you in the rest of the course is
what happens next what happens when
radionuclides are absorbed by animals of
the human body and what was the main
fallout let's say in the in the
colloquial sense and the actual sense
from the chernobyl reactor
let's look a bit what they did next
though
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
i think that pretty much summarizes the
state of things now
the uh they built a sarcophagus around
this reactor a gigantic tomb which
according to some reports is not that
structurally sound and is in danger of
partial collapse
so yeah more difficult efforts are ahead
but let's now talk about
what happened next
i'm going to jump to the very end of
this the actual way that the accident
was noticed
was the spread of the radioactive cloud
to not so close by sweden
so it was noticed that folks entering a
reactor in sweden had contaminants on
them which they thought was coming from
their own reactor good first assumption
when it was determined that nothing was
amiss at the reactor in sweden folks
started to analyze wind patterns and
find out what happened and then it was
clear that the ussr had tried to cover
up the chernobyl accident but you can't
cover up fallout and it eventually
spread
pretty wide covering
most of europe russia and surprisingly
not spain lucky them for the wind
patterns that day or those few days
so what happened is a few days after the
actual accident a graphite fire started
to break out because graphite when
exposed to air well you can do the
chemistry
add graphite plus oxygen
you start making carbon dioxide
so graphite burns when it's hot and as
you can see from the video
where is that nice still of
mold burning graphite yeah that graphite
was pretty hot so a lot of that smoke
included burning graphite and a lot of
the materials from the reactor itself
now when you build up
fission products in a reactor and they
get volatilized like this the ones that
tend to get out first would be things
like the noble gases so the whole xenon
inventory of the reactor was released
it's estimated about a hundred percent
and i can actually pull up those figures
when we talk about how much of which
radionuclide was released
uh that's also a typo if somebody wants
to call in there's no 33 isotope of
xenon it's supposed to be 133.
um that would be interesting if someone
wants to call in and say the nea's got a
mistake
so
100 of the inventory release that should
be pretty obvious because it's a noble
gas and it just kind of floats away
the real dangers though came from iodine
131
about 50 percent
of a three exo-becquerel activity
so we're talking like mega curies or
might be giga can't do that math in my
head a lot a lot of radiation and the
problem with that is iodine behaves just
like any other halogen it forms salts
it's rather volatile if any of you guys
played with iodine before
no one does oh you have okay what
happens when it you play with it i mean
like yeah
and
it just reacts with like acids and stuff
okay
i happen to have extensive practice
playing with iodine in my home because i
did all the stuff you're not supposed to
do as a kid kind of build your own
chemistry step things that somehow you
know leak out of your local high school
somehow
iodine is pretty neat
yeah it happens sometimes
um if you put iodine in your hand it
actually sublimes the heat from your
hand is enough to directly go from solid
to vapor and so the iodine was also
quite volatile some of it may have been
in the form of other compounds some of
it may have been elemental probably not
likely but there was certainly some
iodine vapor and about half of that was
released the problem is then
it condenses out and falls on
anything green anything with surface
area so the biggest danger to the folks
living nearby was from eating leafy
vegetables
because the loads that leaves got loss
of surface area iodine deposits on them
and it's intensely radioactive for a
month or so
or depositing on the grass that cows eat
which led to the problem of radioactive
milk
and so that's why milk in the soviet
union was banned for such a long time
because this was one of the major
sources of iodine contamination
the other one which we're worrying about
now from fukushima as well
is cesium
which has similar chemistry to sodium
and potassium again a rather salty
compound
a rather salty element but it's got a
half-life of 30 years
and if we look it up in the table of
nuclides
we'll see what it actually releases
oh good it's back online
anyone else notice this broken a couple
days ago
well luckily brookhaven national lab has
a good version up too
but let's grab cesium
yeah there's plenty out there
cesium-137
beta decays to barium but also gives off
gamma rays and most of the decays
end up giving off
one of those gamma rays let's say a 660
kev gamma ray so it's both a beta and a
gamma emitter now which of those types
of radiation do you think is more
damaging to biological organisms
the beta or the gamma
you say the gamma why do you say so
doesn't beta get stopped by
it does
but if cesium is better known as
yes
that's right so
did i tell you guys this question the
four cookies question
yeah
you eat the gamma cookie because most
gammas that are emitted by the cookie
simply leave you and irradiate your
friend which is going to be the topic of
piece at number eight
you'll see that's why you guys are
getting your whole body counts
speaking of who's gotten their whole
body counts at ehs
awesome so that's almost everybody you
will need that data for problem set
eight so do schedule it soon
preferably before thanksgiving so that
you'll be able to take a look at it has
anyone found anything interesting in
your spectra
good glad to hear that
but you do see a potassium peak that you
can it probably integrate
and do some problems with right
yeah because you will okay
anyway yeah it's the betas that's the
real killer the gammas are going to
leave the cesium enter your body and
most likely come out the other side
because
the mass attenuation coefficient
of six what is it water for 660 kev
gammas let's find that
table three
let's say you're made mostly of
water
water liquid that's pretty much humans
660 kv is right about here leading to
about
0.1 centimeters squared per gram and
with a density of 1 gram that's a pretty
low attenuation of gammas
so this chart actually shows why most of
the cesium gammas that would be produced
from ingestion just get right out but
it's the betas that have an awfully
short range
anyone remember the formula for range
in general
because it's going to come back up in
our discussion of dose and biological
effects
integral of
yup of stopping power to the negative
one
and that stopping power
is this simple formula
let's see
what did that come out as
log minus beta squared that simple
little formula
which i'm not going to expect you guys
to memorize so don't worry about it but
if you integrate this you find out that
the range of electrons even one mev
electrons in water is not very high so
most of them are stopped
near or by the cells that absorb them
doing quite a bit of damage to the dna
which is eventually what causes
mutagenic effects cancer cell death what
we're going to talk about for the whole
third part of the course
there's also
a worry about which organs actually
absorb these radionuclides and iodine in
particular
is preferentially absorbed by the
thyroid so when we started looking at
the amount of radioactive substances
released remember they said okay at
around
26th of april or the 2nd of may or so
the uh release was stopped not according
to our data that's when the graphite
fire picked up again in addition the
core of chernobyl
which had undergone a mostly total
meltdown
was sitting in a pool
on top of this concrete pad
so let's just call this liquid stuff the
actual word that we use in parlance is
called corium
it's our tongue-in-cheek word for every
element mixed together in a hot
radioactive soup
it's first of all it started to
redistribute reacting with any water
that was present flashing it to steam
and the steam caused additional
dispersion of radionuclides and
eventually it burrowed its way through
and into the ground
releasing more you know it's it's uh
it's the worst nuclear thing that's ever
happened in the history of nuclear
things
quite a mess
and luckily it did sort of taper off
after this
but let's now look into
what happens next and this is the nice
intro to the third part of the course
iodine is is preferentially uptaken by
the thyroid gland somewhere right about
here
so has anyone ever heard of the idea of
taking iodine tablets in the case of a
nuclear disaster
anyone have any idea why
if you saturate your thyroid with iodine
then if you ingest radioactive iodine
it's less likely to be permanently
uptaken
by the thyroid
so this actually provided some
statistics on the probability of getting
thyroid cancer from radioactive iodine
ingestion
luckily the statistics were quite poor
which means that not many people were
exposed it was somewhere around 1300 or
so
not like millions yeah 1300 people total
but what i want to jump to is the
dose versus risk curve and this is going
to belie all of our discussion about the
biological long-term effects of
radioactivity
what's the most striking thing you see
as part of this curve
that's that's right that's the first
thing i saw
there are six different models for how
dose and increased risk of cancer
proceeds and they all fall within
almost all the error bars of these
measurements
i say again thank god that the error
bars are so high because that means that
the sample size was so low
so when folks say we don't really know
how much radioactivity causes how much
cancer they're right because luckily we
don't have enough data from people being
exposed to know that really really well
so some folks say we should be cautious
i kind of agree with them some folks say
the jury's still out i also agree with
them
but you can start to estimate these
sorts of things by knowing how much
radiation energy was absorbed and to
what organ
so i think the only technical thing i
want to go over today
is the different units of dose because
as you start to read things in the
reading which i recommend you do if you
haven't been doing yet you're going to
encounter a lot of different units of
radiation dose
ranging from things like the renkin
which responds to
a number of ionizations
you won't usually see this one
given in sort of biological parlance
because it's the number of ionizations
detected by some sort of gaseous
ionization detector so the dosimeters
that you all put on the did you guys all
bring these uh
these like brass
pendocimeters into the reactor did
anyone look through them to see what the
unit of dose was
it's going to be in renkins because
that's directly correlatable to the
number of ionizations that that
dosimeter has experienced you'll also
see four dose units two of which are
just factors of 100 away from each other
there's what's called the rad
and the gray
and there's what's called the rim
and the sievert
you'll see these approximated as gray
you'll see these as r
and these are just usually written as
rem
so
a rad is simple
let's see
100 rads
is the same as one gray
and 100 rem
is the same as one sievert
and for gamma for the case of gamma
radiation
these units are actually equal
i particularly like this set of units
because
this is the kind of s i of radiation
units because it comes directly from
measurable calculatable quantities like
the gray for example the actual unit of
gray
is joules absorbed
per kilogram of absorber
it's a pretty simple unit to understand
if you know how many radioactive
particles or
gammas or whatever that you have
absorbed you can multiply that number by
their energy divide by the mass of the
organ absorbing them and you get its
dose in gray
sievert
is gray
times some quality factor for the
radiation
times some quality factor
for the specific type of tissue
what this says is that some
types of radiation are more effective at
causing damage than others and some
organs are more susceptible to radiation
damage than others does anyone happen to
know some of the organs that are most
susceptible to radiation damage
soft tissue is like what because there's
lots of those
stomach lining yep yeah
huh
lungs yup what else
thyroid yep there there is definitely
one for thyroid
bone marrow
what other ones
your
brain actually not so much
eyes
and where else do you find rapidly
dividing cells in your body
skin yep the dermis
i don't know about the liver i would
assume so yeah it's a pretty active
organ
but when folks are worried about birth
defects
reproductive organs
the link here that for some reason is
not said in the reading and i've never
figured out why is the more often a cell
is dividing the more susceptible it is
to gaining cancer risk because every
cell division is a copy of its dna
and anytime that radiation goes in and
damages or changes that dna by either
causing what's called a thymine bridge
where two thymine bases get linked
together or damaging the structure in
some other way that
gene is then replicated and the faster
they're replicating the more likely
cancer is going to become apparent
i guess this brings up a question when
does a rapidly dividing cell become
cancer is it division number one or is
it when you notice it
i guess i'll leave that question to the
biologists
but if you notice in the reading you'll
see a bunch of different tissue
equivalency factors
and you'll just see them tabulated and
say there they are memorize them i want
you to try and think of the pattern
between them the tissues that basically
don't matter like the non-marrow part of
the bone
dead skin cells
muscles things that basically aren't
listed that much they're not dividing
very fast but anywhere you find stem
cells the lining of your intestine your
lungs which undergo a lot of
environmental damage need to be
replenished gonads
what was the other one that we said eyes
these are places that are either
sensitive tissues or they're rapidly
dividing
and so the sievert is kind of in a unit
of increased equivalent risk
so that if you were to absorb one gray
of gamma rays
versus one gray of alphas
you'd be about 20 times more likely to
incur cancer from the alphas than the
gammas because the amount of localized
damage that they do to cells and we'll
be doing all this in detail
pretty soon
and then for tissue equivalency factor
if you absorb one gray in your whole
body which means one joule per kilogram
of average body mass
versus one grade directly to the lining
of your intestine by let's say
drinking polonium-laced tea
like happened to a poor was it current
or xkgb guy one of the russian fellows
no it's the kgb guys that poisoned them
right
yeah do you guys remember back in 2010
or so
there was a russian
was he a journalist
xkgb so the current kgb somehow got into
london and slipped polonium into his tea
at a japanese restaurant
uh really i think so right
it was like
what was his name
let's see
poisoning did he actually die
poisoning of alexander lidovenko
he's not doing too well
illness and poisoning death and last
statement
at the hospital in london so
yeah
well
interesting that probably has something
to do with it
yeah well
uh we're not going to comment on the
politics but the uh the radiation effect
worked clearly
unfortunately
so polonium is an alpha emitter and that
caused a massive dose of alphas to his
entire gastrointestinal tract and that
caused a whole lot of damage to those
cells no time for cancer it actually
killed off a lot of those stem cells and
the way that radiation poisoning would
work is that if you kill off the stem
cells the villi in your intestine die
which are responsible for absorbing
nutrition you can't uptake nutrition
you basically starve doesn't matter what
you eat it's messed up
yeah
that's a really bad way to go it's
called gastrointestinal syndrome and
we'll be talking about the progressive
effects of acute radiation exposure
where you have immediate effects mostly
relating to the death of some organ that
is responsible for either cell division
to keep you alive or in extreme cases
your neurological system and nerve
function just stops at the highest
levels of dose and that corresponds to
doses of around
four to six gray four to six joules per
kilogram of villi or body mass
will kill you pretty quickly with very
little chance of survival as what
happened here
and so this was the problem with all the
folks living
around and near chernobyl and ukraine
and belarus and everywhere was the
contamination was pretty extensive
about 4 000 people are estimated to have
died or contracted cancer from this i
can't believe how low that number is but
it's still 4 000 people that it should
never happen to and effects were felt
far away in towns like amel and can't
read that one because there's not enough
pixels
because of the way that let's say rain
water
wist or let's say um the vapor cloud
from the reactor was whisked away rain
water caused it to fall on certain
places which still to this day can have
a really large contamination area
and this brings me a little bit into
what should we be worried about from
fukushima
a whole lot less than chernobyl and the
reason why is fukushima did undergo a
hydrogen explosion and did and still
continues to release
cesium-137 into the ocean luckily for us
the ocean is big
and except for fish caught right near
around fukushima even though
concentrations can be measured at
hundreds to thousands of times normal
concentrations they can still be
hundreds to thousands of times lower
than the safe consumption
so
a lot of the
problems you see in the news today i'm
not going to call them lies but i'm
going to call them half truths folks
will show the radiation plume of
cesium-137 escaping from fukushima and
that's true there is radiation escaping
the question is is it high enough to
cause a noticeable
increased risk of cancer
that's the question that reporters
should be asking themselves when they
only tell the half of the story that
gets them viewers and they don't tell
the half of the story to complete the
story
and tell you should you be afraid or not
because unfortunately fear brings
viewers
this is the problem and i'm happy to go
on camera saying this this is the
problem with the media today
is with a half truth and with a half
story you can incite real panic over
non-physical issues that may not
actually exist
and so it's important that the media
tell the whole story
yes it's true that fukushima's leasing
releasing cesium-137
how much though is the question that
people and the media should be asking
themselves and in the rest of this
course we're going to answer the
question how much is too much
so i'm going to stop here
since it's two of five of and ask you
guys if you have any questions on
the whole second part of the course or
what happened in chernobyl
yeah yeah could you explain the equality
factor term and
how you find that
yep the quality fat well there's two
quality factors there's the quality
factor for radiation
which will tell you how much let's say
how much more cell damage a given amount
of a given type of radiation of the same
energy will deposit into a cell
and the tissue equivalency factor tells
you well what's the added risk
of some sort of defect leading to cell
death or cancer or some other defect
from that radiation absorption
so to me the tissue equivalency factor
is
roughly but not completely approximated
by the cell division rate
and the
radiation quality factor is going to be
quite proportional to the stopping power
you'll see a term
called the linear energy transfer or let
this is the
stopping power unit used in the biology
community it's stopping power and
luckily the turner reading actually says
it's somewhere buried in a paragraph let
is stopping power so if you start
plotting these two together you might
find some striking similarities
i saw two other questions up here
yeah it's gonna ask uh
why is chernobyl still considered like
off limits of most the half-lives of
these things are like on the range by
days to
let's answer that with numbers so most
of the half-lives were on the range of
days to hours
but still cesium-137 with a half-life of
30 years released
a third of an exo-becquerel that's one
of the major sources of contamination
still out there in addition if we scroll
down a little more
there was quite a bit of plutonium
inventory with a half-life of 24 000
years
so on on friday we're going to have jake
heckler come in and give his chernobyl
travelogue because one of our seniors
has actually been to chernobyl and his
boots were so contaminated with
plutonium that he can never use them
again they got to stay wrapped up in
plastic so some of these things last
tens of thousands of years
and even though there weren't a lot of
petabeckerals of plutonium released
they're alpha emitters and they're
extremely dangerous when ingested
so
greens and things that uptake
radionuclides from the soil like moss
and mushrooms are totally off limits in
a large range of this area
you will find a video online if you look
of a mayor from a nearby town saying oh
they're perfectly safe to eat look i eat
them right here and
i just say read the comments for what
people have to say about that
not too smart
yeah so what's like the process now for
like taking care of
what are they
doing
so the sarcophagus around the reactor
has got to be shored up to make sure
that nothing else gets out because most
of the reactor is still there
and let's say rain water comes in and
starts washing away more stuff into the
ground or whatever we don't want that to
happen
soil replacement and disposal as nuclear
waste is still going on
uh removal of any moss lichen mushrooms
or anything with a sort of radiation
exposure has got to keep going but this
the area that it covers is enormous i
don't know if we're ever going to get
rid of all of it the question is how
much do we have to get rid of to lower
our risk of cancer in the area to an
acceptable rate there will likely be
parts of this that are inaccessible for
thousands to tens of thousands of years
unless we hopefully get smarter about
how to contain and dispose of this kind
of stuff
we're not there yet so right now the
methods are
kind of simple get rid of the soil
fence off the area
some folks have been returning and they
do get compensation and free medical
visits because the background levels
there are elevated but not that high so
folks have started to move back to some
of these areas
but there's a lot that are still off
limits
any other questions
yeah it's like way worse than the atomic
bombs dropped on hiroshima and nagasaki
because those are like fully functioning
cities at this point
yeah the number of deaths from the
atomic bombs way outweighed the number
of deaths that will ever happen from
chernobyl like why is the radiation from
those bombs not
oh not that much of an issue there
wasn't that much material that not there
wasn't that much nuclear material in an
atomic bomb
what did you guys get for the radius of
the critical sphere of plutonium
centimeters yeah
doesn't take a lot it takes you know 10
20 kilos
to make a weapon now we're talking about
tons or thousands of tons of material
released so
an atomic weapon doesn't kill by
radiation it kills by pressure wave the
heat wave
the fallout is not as much of a concern
and we'll actually be looking at the
data from hiroshima and nagasaki
survivors to see who got what dose what
increased cancer risk did they get and
is this the
is the idea that every little bit of
radiation is a bad thing actually true
the answer is you can't say yes or no
no one can say yes or no because we
don't have good enough data
the error bars support either conclusion
so i'm not going to go on record and say
a little bit of radiation's okay data is
not out yet hopefully it never will be
any other questions
all right i'll see you guys on thursday
you